I'm just trying to get people out of the
the mindset that every hamburger place
should be the same the hamburger
transcends everything it's been around
forever and it's not going to go
anywhere my name is George Moes and I'm
a hamburger expert I can safely say that
because I've spent seems like a lifetime
eating hamburgers researching hamburgers
writing about hamburgers I've got books
got a couple of TV shows I host the show
Burger scholar sessions and finally
after all this time I have my own
restaurant right here in New York City
called hamburger America I can't believe
it it actually
happened this is a restaurant well it's
not a restaurant yet but it's almost a
restaurant as you can see painting is
happening now painting and cleaning and
is about to be a vacuuming
noise this is well there's the vacuum
noise there it
is this is the sound of progress this is
progress I call it a piece of living
hamburger history it's my love letter to
the hamburger telling the regional story
of the hamburger is the fun part for me
because I'm actually able to identify
why different Burgers have different
styles in different regions and in the
same way the Texas barbecue is very
different from North Carolina Barbecue
you know a green chili cheeseburger is
very different from a butter burger for
example you look at any any hamburger
cookbook out out there it's all about
you know here's a burger we put avocado
on it it's a California Burger which
[__] my mission I've said so many
times before is to protect the American
hamburger there a lot going on in here
this is the dining room in the back we
have three booths here
beautiful uh upholstered in the color of
American
cheese set against wood grain which to
me is so soothing nothing more soothing
than that I think the bathrooms are
almost too beautiful this is the first
time a wallpaper has ever made one to
eat a
cheeseburger it's not to be kitchy and
stupid the whole point of this place is
to be
evocative what I'm doing is I'm shining
a light on something that people don't
take very seriously or never really
taken seriously and in part because of
the fast food world ruined the image of
the Great American hamburger I really
feel it is my duty to make sure people
are appreciating the hamburger in a
different
way when I was first discovering the
beauty of the American hamburger I felt
like being the people I was going to
talk to in these hamburger joints they
said hey what what's the big deal why
are you so excited about this hamburger
it's it's just a
hamburger I had a hard time trying to
convince people that what they were
doing was
important to me it's one of the most
authentic American forms of Gest front
of
me this is it 12 stools on the counter
right here this is where all the action
is classic hamburger joints don't use
big fancy griddles and big fancy
equipment they use very basic equipment
that's how you achieve the goal of the
perfect cheeseburger you look at history
these things have been around for 100
years look at these curves man look at
these beautiful curves look at that look
at that I mean hamburger places like
this keep closing all the time and want
to make sure that this place embodies a
piece of history that we're losing very
quickly I have four of my really large
format photos in the back from hamburger
joints and pretty much all four of those
are the direct inspiration for this
place the convention grill in ed in
Minnesota The Apple Pan in Los Angeles
the Shady Glenn in Manchester
Connecticut the white Mana in Jersey
these are hugely inspirational to me for
sure by the way if you look at it this
is very important you're kind of inside
of a cheese cheesburger you got the
American cheese here see that you got
the brown is kind of the beef the light
brown is kind of the bun I got this idea
from the Shady
Glenn you go to The Apple Pan and you go
to White mana and you want to sit down
you wait behind someone who's finishing
we have a nice sign here right here that
says you know grab a seat to the counter
grab a stool at the counter if you can't
find a stool you stand behind someone
who's finishing or paying or eating
dessert we didn't build this restaurant
for you to hang out here for hours we
love you but the guy behind you looks
hungry it's been a couple weeks we're so
close so
close this is very exciting I haven't
been here in a couple of days here oh my
God hey
stools look at the stools
woo check that out oh wow first I've
seen these oh feels
good look at this
wow that's amazing look at the lights
they beautiful
oh look at
this first I've seen of this those are
not the right whoops those are not the
that's not
right that's not
correct that will change okay well what
triggered my hamburger Obsession in the
very beginning was my
1994 I was in Los Angeles at the Apple
Pan and at that point I just assumed
that every Burger was like you know my
dad's Backyard Burger or Wendy McDonald
Burger King thing and it wasn't I sat
that the Apple Pan and I was blown away
I was first time I was ever LA and it
felt like I was on a movie
set Place seemed totally unreal I mean
it was guys wearing paper caps you'd ask
for fries and they would [__] [__] [__]
they put ketchup on a plate for you
right next to the fries I didn't ask for
ketchup he didn't care I was in and out
of there in 15 minutes I had one of the
most amazing burgers and I thought to
myself okay this isn't actually I've
never had this kind of experience before
this exists I felt my job then at that
point was to start to seek out these
places I became obsessed with going on
location I was a filmmaker I would go on
location I would seek out the best
hamburger spot I could find at some
point I wanted to make a documentary
about some kind of food and I realized
I'm already obsessed with hamburgers why
don't I just do that and I started to
discover that there are a lot of great
stories out there that are just right
outside the mainstream anybody told me
that you know when I was sitting at the
Apple Pan almost 30 years ago that I'd
be sitting at my own restaurant 30 years
later say what you're
insane the restaurant was the next
logical step because I couldn't get the
hamburger musical off the
ground I tried it's true was a True
Story by the way I had all the right
people in in place the name of the play
is called Max lunch and uh it's about a
small hamburger joint that's about to be
torn down it's a David and Goliath
Story the floor pattern is funny because
the architect and myself spent a lot of
time looking at floors and going to
restaurants and looking
down and we discovered U that there were
there was a very specific pattern to
most hamburger joints in American and
other diners that is relative to you
know Diner and lunch inet history if you
look at the tables and the counters it's
something
called uh linen it's a linen for Mica
pattern this is something I've seen in a
lot of different burger joints and
diners around the country because of the
8 to 10% gray surface we chose when you
take a picture of a burger it should
expose
perfectly I'd spent so much time telling
people about hamburgers you know
interview and in on Burger scholar
sessions on the burger show enlightening
Alvin was was one of the those great
moments in my life Alvin was so
genuinely excited about hamburger
history I could take all those Burgers
I've been making on the show I can take
the burger I've been making all over the
world for years the Oklahoma frat onion
burger and put it to put it at a counter
and build the ideal uh piece of
hamburger history Burger scholar session
moment that we had during the pandemic
changed a lot and they would say say to
me you know I know how to cook now
because of you I can make burgers I can
do this I I didn't you know I told you
you could do it you could do it I told
you I'm so excited they love the show
but now they get to come here which is
even cooler I think so I believe that
hamburger America would exist to offer
not just food but also an explanation if
you will hey guys I need there going be
a lot of yelling going on screaming and
yelling but here we are this is it this
is where I'm going to be standing right
here oh God yeah it it feels now
actually didn't feel real until today
it's really bizarre I I've been watching
it being built but these guys have done
such a great job putting the details
together that it actually finally feels
like like my
restaurant really
[Music]
does all the places I've seen all around
the world country especially that the
most successful ones are the ones that
only have a few things in the men a
burger fries and a drink when you focus
on only one thing you do a much better
job than trying to focus on a 100
there's two burgers in the menu there's
the fried onion burger that I've been
making for years and I also offered a
second Burger which is a classic Smash
Burger that I'm serving all the way with
Mustard Pickle onion Mustard Pickle
onion goes back probably 120 years
onions being the first condiment there
obviously are some Regional favorites of
mine that I would have put on the menu
but I decided to skip it because we're
going to do this thing called the
hamburger Heroes program and these are
people that I believe I owe a lot to
because they really wouldn't be sit
sitting here right now in my own
restaurant had I not really studied them
and understood why they do what they do
to honor that I'm bringing them to the
restaurant we'll bring them in for a
weekend make the burger right here at
the griddle and then keep that burger on
the on the menu for the month Marty Hall
from SIDS will definitely be here I've
already asked him he's excited to be
here it's going to be fun I already have
the first two and a half years lined
up yeah so so there's like
a we're going to count to three we're
going to cut a ribbon but first drum
roll please Carl
one
two
3 hey there you
go thank you thanks everyone thank
[Music]
you thanks
everybody oh
hi who who are all these people what is
going on
[Applause]
[Music]
here my name is Ed Sullivan I'm here
from Brennan and car restaurant in
Brooklyn we've been in business 90 years
definitely proud of of George glad to
see him on his terms with me where I'm
not working so I want to see George
sweat a
little I've been following George's
videos on YouTube probably for the last
couple years this was an easy chance for
me to try the thing that looks really
good on the internet my name is Luis
Ortega I came uh from the Dominican
Republic just to try George
spurg I think it went as best as it
could like the good news is I think
people are very very excited and that's
the most important part a lot of very
excited people about hamburgers I'm
really really genuinely excited it's
wild right I I love doing it I think I
love doing it people keep saying you
need to take a break you need to stop
I'm like I know but I'm Making burgers
and I look up and I see I just there a
guy went to high school was sitting
there the enormity of the whole damn
thing has not hit me at all and I don't
know what it's going to hit me I'm sure
it will at some point but I've never
been the guy with the big scissors that
was pretty cool
[Music]
George Moes Burger scholar here please
like And subscribe watch more episodes
hit a button somewhere here hang on I
got a phone call hello Neil what
happened you okay